well there's been a lot of negative
thoughts on the north end of the strip
because there are even more lane changes
now for that ongoing repaving and
improvement project
our hector mejia reports that all of the
northbound lanes
have been moved to the southbound side
that sounds like a recipe for a disaster
actor
it sure does let's just go ahead and
call this the big squeeze junior as you
just mentioned all northbound lanes
switched over to the southbound side and
this is where it starts where we see
crews right now digging into the earth
here
trying to fix las vegas boulevard this
is where the lane changes and the
closures begin on las vegas boulevard
right at elvis presley and it's
happening all week long
from elvis presley boulevard up to
sahara clark county calls us a
significant closure
and since it's lasting all week long
until 2 pm on friday they're asking you
to go ahead and plan ahead so clark
county as we've been telling you they're
expecting traffic delays especially
during rush hour
this round of closures began yesterday
causing some stop
and go traffic in the middle of the day
here in front of circus circus
and it's part of the ongoing project one
of seven phases making improvements
along las vegas boulevard
right now crews are repaving the
northbound lanes they're also replacing
a water line
improving crosswalks adding new light
poles in the meantime drivers are just
left
navigating the orange cones
it's a nightmare trying to find parking
trying to do anything i don't see
anybody out here kind of directing
traffic
helping maybe move it along it is like a
free for all
so this morning we do see people here
helping drivers navigate through the
closures
you can take some side streets though
the closest ones are resorts world drive
and denting boulevard
you can also try to venture out if you'd
like by taking desert in
paradise or even convention center which
is down the street from here and back
out here you see
crews working right now before it gets
even hotter again all northbound lanes
shifted over to the southbound side this
is where that starts
elvis presley boulevard all the way up
to just down the street from here
down to sahara on las vegas boulevard
reporting live hector mckia
8 news now back to you